I'm a black man in Beverly feels
this is it I knew huh no began its what
are you wearing a bar we about how you
got it this enjoyed it welcome neighbors
we are that's miss my name is Carl
balearic it's a little ironic that that
your name is black don't watch it [ __ ]
what that's the first morning tonight is
the purge doing done nothing wrong got
nothing worried about her Jane about you
it's about the rest of you and you know
who you are oh my god tonight's only the
most dangerous night all year people can
get away whatever crime they won't for
12 hours mr. back and I'd wanted here
I'm going to cut the power now maybe if
you smile it would help us find you in
the dark we on lockdown it can't do
lucky to us you have to pay your debt
tonight I never seen a pit bull with a
prior
who's can [ __ ] whoever let you walk out
the house with that jacket it's not your
friend that you can move into my
neighbor waving your hands in the area
but you just don't care sounds like we
normal
died everyone movie over white people
don't do so that we're all going to them
you won't die if you keep talking I'm
just talking about yoga got mixed one
more place around here cuz they will
snitch
come over proof click click click I'll
back shoot all called flags think you
can run me out this might house up on
the hood your car block from Chicago
right there and your Caesar from the
planet of age don't put that Ebola
finger in my face